Now we're going to examine Unreal's project logic and its approach to shot production.
It's not a coincidence that Unreal Engine's project structure bears a certain similarity to the structure of film production organization.
The Unreal Engine project is designed with progressive layers of complexity controlling scenes, actors, and various technical capabilities.
Like nested containers, each entity handles a specific function and communicates with each other to help you produce your final film.
This film analogy continues to integrate the way Unreal refers to its sequence terminology.
While there are many new game-centric terms and tools that a user will have to learn,
sequencer can accommodate more common workflows like accessing specific scene assemblies,
supporting multiple performance takes, camera layouts, shot construction, and sequence organization.
This brings us to sequencer, one of the central tool sets in Unreal for creating linear animated content.
Sequencer is designed to function as a non-linear editing and assembly tool.
Actors from the viewport or assets from the content browser are added into sequencer to create level sequence assemblies.
The best way to think about a level sequence is to think of it as a virtual container that holds 3D animated footage that's spread across time.
Level sequences can be nested inside of one another through the use of a shot track to insert shots into longer sequences and beats of action.
Combined with sequencer's take system, the user is capable of creating sophisticated nested hierarchies similar to the way films are organized.
Films contain sequences, sequences contain shots, and shots can have various takes.
Sequencer's UI is fairly simple. There is a toolbar where all of your primary tools and settings are located.
There is also the track outliner that stores the items that you wish to animate.
There is the timeline where the shots, keyframes, and animation sequences in sub-scene tracks reside.
And finally, there is a set of playback controls down in the left-hand corner.
Sequencer can also access two very important sets of tools.
The event manager used to trigger specific events and blueprints at specific points of time on the timeline, and the curve editor,
a traditional editor used to modify keyframes, their curves, and tangents.
Another crucial tool is the level editor.
Project organization is critical for organizing your environment through various sub-levels.
The primary level that pairs specifically with your master level sequence contains the persistent level.
By default, anything added to the level will be placed here.
By double-clicking on any additional sub-levels, actors can be placed on that sub-level to be used for specific purposes.
Depending upon your particular project, levels and sub-levels can be used to organize your environment, lighting, effects, or whatever you need.
Within Sequencer, these levels can be turned on or off by using visibility tracks.
The sub-scene track is a specific sequencer entity that allows you to layer level sequences within a level sequence for the sake of departmental organization.
Please note, this feature is different from nesting level sequences together through the shot track, which is used to insert shots into a longer sequence.
Sub-scene tracks are level sequences that handle very specific types of animation.
For example, a specific sub-scene track can be devoted to handling various effects that you wish to layer into your shot, like Niagara particles.
Sub-scene tracks can be nested as many times as necessary to separate work between various departments or artists.
Since they are level sequences, they are saved as separate files that can be checked out via source control for work without interfering with other artists working on your sequence.
The next concept we're going to explore is actor persistence.
In Unreal, actors are one of three types, possessibles, spawnables, or replacables.
Possessible actors persist in a level indefinitely, and they can be controlled or shared by multiple level sequences.
If you know you have specific actors or characters that will be used regularly, keeping them as possessible makes sense for ease of access and repetitious use.
Spawnable actors only exist within the active level sequence. They're identified within Sequencer and the Outliner by a lightning bolt icon.
This type of persistence is excellent for temporary actors who are needed for specific needs within the shot.
Perhaps some extra lights, or a background actor who shows up just for the shot and then is no longer required.
The idea of spawnables is appealing because it can keep your level and its environment free of unnecessary actors when they're not needed.
The final form of persistence is replaceable actors. This blueprint-driven form of persistence is dictated by the binding lifetime track and allows you to swap out actors as needed.